pan
pascal voir alors on va faire une hyper
vis à vis que c'est une hyper dur oui je
vous ai regardé quand vous êtes prêts à
l'y fiable mais avant de faire l'hyper
bio je peux prêt à tout mais je suis
prêt l'interview avant avant de faire du
permis ou vous savez que le plateau
précédents ont parlé en parler des
femmes avec schirrhein ont étendu
jusqu'à ce une merveilleuse cash ou qui
étaient avec nous vous les mecs à chaud
je rencontre contre elle très bien dit
ça parce que franchement il vaut mieux
alors
alors non sur les femmes vous avez
déclaré
physiquement la fidélité physiquement
physiquement la fidélité est une énorme
plaisanterie vous croyez pas à la
fidélité aux je fais une différence
entre la mort physique à l'amour tout
court et donc la fidélité c'est celle de
l'âme et du coeur je suis de fidélité
physique je crois pas c'est un peu
d'hypocrisie
bon j'en dis ça pour robert hue parce
que d'un coup il a eu un fils est parti
il a été un peu et non 8 avait secoué
ben crois qu'il faut pas mélanger
ça peut être mais l'amour peut se
concrétiser par la mort physique mais ce
n'est pas un tout l'amour c'est très
différent de la mort faisant très grave
votre premier grand amour va pas tarder
la boue ils arrivent menu il arrive
alors votre premier à annoncer vous
monique votre premier amour votre ami un
grand amour s'appelait monique c'est
comme certaines filières j'adore vous
avez trouvé tout cela oui c'est vrai ah
ouais c'était une fille de médecin bruit
mouzat celui moment et vous l'avez pas
épouser donc non ça et maintenant les
mères de famille à limoges
elle vit avec un journaliste à limoges
et à leur trouver un nom voilà bien
parce que j'aurais dit
non menu ce n'est pas l'arrivée mais a
eu une défaillance voilà si vous aviez
pascal si vous avez quelque chose à te
manquer compris si vous aviez quelque
chose si vous aviez quelque chose à dire
à monique au bruit
attendez attendez attendez à quoi pascal
mais n'a pas revu monique depuis de
longues années
et là il va lui dire un jet pack cette
émission tellement sentimentale seront
plus qu'un soir je me dis venez vous a
fait venir justement de demain ou
devienne son rôle à fond paroles de
chanson française dont on va parler de
la france hormis bonjour je me souviens
quand on avait 15 ans et qu'on allait se
produire le jardin de son père d'amélie
ravi d'avoir à vie voilà voilà
monique parce que marisa les caennais
ravis et l'aveyron bien son sac et la n3
jamais parlé bon alors maintenant on va
vraiment passé à l'hyper bio alors
pascal sevran c'est pas votre vrai nom
un nom c'est comment votre vrai nom jean
claude jours ouais on comprend qu'il ait
changé en même temps le nombre du mois
c'est long c'est pas ça c'est le nom
d'un grand oui eh bien c'est pour ça que
je changeais à et en plus c'est le nom
d'un grand syndicaliste
oui ah ouais ça j'étais léon jouhaux son
nom d'un général putschiste et
bouteilles contre la réhabilitation des
généraux putschistes vous avez ça vous a
pas plu quand on a réhabilité les
généraux putschistes et y avait un jour
oui je trouve que ce n'est pas urgent
ouais c'était pas urgence de ces jeux
c'est une piste rennais aurait pu
chanter c'est un jour go pourrait venir
elle freiner alors votre botte surnom
ces nounous chez moi je sais ma mère
mais j'adore joly enfin je sais pas j'ai
passé j'ai passé l'âge quand même au
beau le jour ma mère serait ce comme ça
c'est mignon du louche et alors vous
avez atteint et nous nous chez prédire
ont failli reprendre
on peut dire votre âge si vous voulez un
jaune à paris si vous ne rajoutez pas on
n'a pas dit lâche 2,6 wright la 56 ans
on compte le temps de défaire sur les
six vieilles paires bon alors vous avez
50 de oui et vous avez déclaré la jeune
c'est une phrase pas mal pour ça que je
la cite la jeunesse n'est pas une
supériorité c'est un avantage
oui donc ya pas de raison de son fier
d'avoir un nom il ya bien aucun cas
comme la petite du business mais avec
seydou gens là
alors vous étiez l'écrivain vous et
écrivain et animateur télé vous êtes
chanteur et alors il ya un disque que je
le montre à la caméra comme on fait la
télé un peu du fond je n'étais pas mieux
pour ça mais six mois mais attendez moi
je fais le boulot moi c'est bien chez
comme arthur moi et je montre à la
caméra comme ça tu vois là c'est le dise
de pascal voilà voilà
alors vos parents votre père était
chauffeur de taxi communiste et votre
mère travaillait chez sia par elie qui
est une grande maison de couture
donc dès le départ vous aviez le goût du
peuple et le goût du luxe finalement
c'est à cette info c'est très bien c'est
en bas c'est vous voilà j'ai trouvé qui
vous attend dans vos premier boulot
c'était garçon coiffeur
ouais hein ma mère avait trouvé que
c'était bien parce qu'à l'époque on
faisait son service militaire et mais
des comme ça ils termineront pas tu vas
tu alors que prévu et avait très bien vu
l'idée est de faire tuer à la guerre tu
feras le coiffeur donc je coiffe et
toutes les femmes de généraux de la
place de paris et alors alors oui vous
ai connus quand justement charles trenet
un jour charles trenet vous le
rencontrez vous invite à aix en provence
vous y allez et vous allez vie minutes
de retard et charles trenet cas un
caractère je dirais que enfin votre
caractère et demi à côté c'est rien
charles trenet huit minutes de retard il
s'était barré il m'a dit d'aller rendez
vous huit mois avant
oui et je l'avais votre changement
d'éditeur vous aimez je faisais des
premières chansons et venez donc on fait
des grèves est né le 12 juillet à à
12h05
et je trouve ça très bien cette
fantaisie des horaires comme ça mais
c'était huit mois avant et j'aime assez
la ponctualité de jeu j'avais une toute
petite voiture et on était vraiment
attendu aujourd'hui les gendarmes
monsieur trenet et iv je vous attendrai
devant la gendarmerie et donc à
l'attendu gamme est allé voir les
gendarmes qui ont dit monsieur trenet
n'attend jamais il est parti voilà je
vous l'avais retrouvé au bord de sa
piscine quelques instants plus tard
quand on peut dire la bd on avait vu mes
livres il ya au moins un animateur
télévision qui sait lire bien entendu et
j'ai vu dans un de vos livres que
c'était pas séguéla qu'avait trouvé la
force tranquille mais léon blum voilà et
en cela par vous que personne jamais n'a
relevé cela personne savait mais malgré
ces françois mitterrand quand je lui
avais dit
il est fait comme ça mais oui c'est une
phrase de bloem le jour de son
investiture sur les marches de matinale
entendu je trouve ça extraordinaire
vous savez pour être animateur télé
c'est pas la peine de savoir lire c'est
fait pour ça alors bon vous êtes région
centre et s'appelait alors pascal sevran
vous êtes on peut le dire sans vous
vexer vous êtes un admirateur nez vous
admirez vous aimé admiré les gens je
vous interromps pour vous dire que quand
on a la prétention extraordinaire comme
vous et moi de me montrer devant les
caméras
ça veut dire qu'on a quelques
prétentions à se faire regarder
peut-être admirez donc le mot la moindre
d humilité c'est nous-mêmes d'amour dose
admiration il ya en effet des artistes
des écrivains et des hommes et les
femmes qui ne sont ni artiste ni
écrivain que j'ai admiré
oui je sens qu'on va est venu je suis
capable de beaucoup d'admiration il faut
un équilibre quand on a cet incroyable
mégalomanie qu'est la note de monter sur
scène vous admirez vous vous admirez des
gens par exemple mais je suis une très
grande fan de liza minnelli la liza
minnelli booth et qui vous admirez le
plus au monde le plus aux moules la
personne que vous admirez le plus là
vous me posez une dent de la question
j'ai jeu je sais pas un apparat par
pascal sevran
je sais pas il ya plein de gens jazeera
fidel castro non non enfin il ya trente
ans il ya trente ans s'est tiré artistes
rock et les gens chez moi c'est laurent
ruquier et viau vous admire et qui voit
là c'est clair moi une bonne chanteuse
sera pas mal ça va parler alors mais
vous aimé admiré c'est votre mère qui
disait quand il était petit pascal enfin
d'une louche est il si les mêmes les
semelles de ses chaussures
j'ai toujours été assez maniaque de la
propreté et l'ordre et j'aime bien que
ça soit en ordre
est-ce que vous admirez xavier
gouyou-beauchamps pas énormément très
bien
se dire qu'il aime vraiment l'ordre
parce que j'avais emmené mes enfants sur
son plateau équipé près des arts et je
vais renvoyer dans la loge du vitrail où
elle emmène ses gosses partout oui je
souffre physiquement sur une émission
elle ajouté elle est élue elle était sur
mon plateau c'est que ardisson accouche
les stars donc vous êtes vous admiriez
dalida ça c'est que c'est connu qui nous
a présenté à françois mitterrand après
vous avez aimé mitterrand vous allez
admirer mitterrand et vous dites j'aime
mitterrand pour ce qu'on lui reproche
aussi j'ai aussi pour ce qu'on lui
reproche
bonjour thierry 6 ici aussi pour ce
qu'on lui reproche dire qu'on voulait
c'est à dire que vous voulez mais aussi
pour busqué pour la francisque et tout
ça oui si vous voulez qu'on fasse une
émission là dessus que je peux pas une
émission je veux tenir la distance
oui oui absolument c'est un homme que
j'ai j'ai aimé et admiré avant de
rencontrer et j'avais aimé la voir ses
livres ce qu'ils disent à la manière de
conduire sa vie et est de réfléchir
alors je suis pas un admirateur imbécile
et béat
tout n'a pas toujours fait plaisir je
les écris dans un livre je sais mais ça
m'agace quand ce qu'ils ont mangé dans
sa main si longtemps trahissent la
gratitude et le lot commun
un jour j'ai dit c'est quand même
mitterrand il a fait écouter la moitié
du pays vous m'avez répondu c'est normal
pour un présent dans le public les
traits les coudées franches et j'aime
que mu city bonne trame et j'aime c'est
à mourir de rire quand on vous écoute
comme je suis d'ailleurs très vexé il
m'appelle directement non mais tous les
ans ça c'est pas très sérieux tout ça
n'a aucune importance
non mais vous êtes avec jacques chirac à
ce que je peux dire si vous êtes avec
jacques lamquet qui étaient dans la
dernière émission d'une fidélité
inébranlable au président mitterrand
derrière cela coûtait la tête de la
liste européenne magie la preuve en tout
cas que françois mitterrand écoutait
tous les france mais qu'est ce qu'on
voudrait exactement on voudrait que que
jack lang renie un homme à qui il doit
tout de même qu'il admirait lui la
parole hier pour une place sur une liste
si c'était le cas ça n'est pas si tout
ça pour aller emmerder la tourasse bourg
après avoir écrit
dit ce que je pensais de cet homme là
que j'aille cracher sur sa tombe
ça n'est pas mon genre vous escaladez
vous grimpez toujours solutré ou pas on
la faible depuis qu'il n'est plus là oui
parce qu'il avait trouvé que c'était
bien et puis voilà faut quelques signes
comme ça de fidélité vous sentez plus
étoile des neiges à la fin des déjeuners
ces grands gags web seulement il aimait
juge explique mitterrand sinon n'étaient
pas invités à la réunion on y était avec
pascal et mitterrand à la fin des
déjeuners
il y avait roger hanin qui était obligé
de raconter la même histoire c'était
toujours la chemise lilas et vous vous
chantiez étoile des neiges que quand il
a commencé sa campagne électorale
c'était une chanson à succès et il me
dit je me souviens que dans tous les
endroits où nous allions faire des
meetings les français à cette époque
chanter cette chanson là or cela
l'amusait plongée relater ce petit
événement mais ça le faisait bouger
raconte très bien il était très drôle
c'était un truc de famille très gentille
voilà alors moi ils me demandent et
chanter j'avais pas été oublié les
paroles parce qu'ils ont engagé le tegra
voilà et voyez quand on a une grande
chanson populaire ses sabots alors vous
êtes on parlait tout à l'heure
d'animateur télé qui savait lire ou pas
ils vont tous les cas vous savez écrire
parce que vous avez écrit plein de
romans dont tu as le passé
supplémentaires qui le prix ni en 79 et
c'est c'est bien parce qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup
moi je rêve de la voir depuis dix ans je
n'ai jamais vous l'avez si vous
travaillez avec je passe moi écrire là
il faut les écrire ça suffit pas de les
recopier faut les écrire alors alors
vous vous dites vous dit
j'écrirai vraiment puisque en ce moment
vous écrivez mais c'est difficile en
faisant le métier qu'on fait bien
entendu vous dites j'écrirai quand je
serai dirait et si vous n'êtes pas virer
moi j'écris quand même une avancée crée
tous les matins et donc il ne rompt pas
d'alibi alors la chance aux chansons
c'est tous les après midi sur france 2
fait même quinze ans ça fait 15 ans
c'est une institution
cette émission alors on vous doit la
nostalgie bon ça mieux partagée par tout
le monde trouvait berck sound x et le
rire majdic c'est la nostalgie vaille et
richard après de l'est tout de suite la
chanson aouichaoui il faut pas il faut
que quel que soit l'âge que l'on est
quel que soit l'âge que l'on est la
nostalgie est à un tour aussi pour
l'homme tout de suite mais quelle que
soit la sympathie se fera dans le passé
supplémentaire qui est donc le livre qui
est le prix mini en 79 vous dit en
parlant de la passion du rugby en
parlant du personnage principal vous dit
sa principale passion était pour les
chanteuses minable est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas un peu dévoilé en écrivant ça
j'aurais pu trouver un adjectif un
objectif plus plus approprié j'aime bien
les chanteuse de beuglant les chanteuses
de bastringue les chanteuses populaires
toujours été ému par fin quand j'étais
petit garçon justement il y avait ces
chanteuses un peu ouais alors dernière
question sais pas pourquoi vous détestez
jane birkin et vanessa paradis pourquoi
il ya longtemps qu'on me payait
longtemps et en tant qu'on ne me parle
plus de ça je définis détester est un
mot que j'emploie très modérément
pourquoi je resterai une femme aussi
charmante que jane birkin
sauf que si on me dit que c'est une
chanteuse l'a évidemment je tort un peu
le nez ouais mais c'est une femme d
c'est une femme délicieuse ravissante
c'est tout c'est lio elle trouve refuge
dans la toile est méfiant alors lio je
craque devant elle quand je vois donc
même enceinte et je lui laisse même
amené les gosses sur le plateau c'est
vous dire mes collaborateurs
élaborateurs me diront mais quand on la
voit plus belle que ça c'est pas
possible
très bien bon ben voilà c'est l hyper
view donc maintenant qu' un caddie bravo
que l'applaudir parce que j'aimerais ce
pas vu l'interview plané ces enfants
sont les plateaux de pascal sevran il ya
pas mal de grands mères % d'occuper
quand je sais ça au jour le plateau il
ya des jeunes gens ça vous plairait
beaucoup pour mon cher laurent raymond
cyr pascal que vous savez les choisir
bon vanessa paradis non non faut il faut
pas me faire dire des choses méchant je
suis gentil simplement elle parle de
change reçu sa saison alors quand on me
demande quand on me demandait si c'est
j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire que
j'aime bien qu'une très gentil moi je
crois je le pense interview dans ton
camp tomber bal de charité review que
m'excuser quand on parle de chanteuse je
pense à quelqu'un d'autre
quelques-unes d'autres accords donc
après l'hyper viewed pascal sevran on
passe au talk show